[Music]
I'm cutting the Rope now hendrik get
under his legs Johannes the preparators
teetered on the wooden ladder the knife
clutched in his right hand he heard
Hendrik moving into position
the man's bulky frame making the boards
of the gallows creak are you ready
Hendrik grunted an affirmative Johannes
began to cut it was only an hour past
sunset but already the streets around
them were deserted it was mid-january
and bitterly cold Johannes expected the
canal to freeze some time in the night
for now though he still heard its waters
lapping gently at the boat halls that in
the huffing breath of the horse standing
nearby were the only sounds in the
settling darkness Johannes finally
managed to saw through the fibers and
all at once the corpse dropped into
hendricks waiting arms almost knocking
him off his feet Johannes hurried down
the ladder to help tucking the small
blade into his coat steady there I've
got his arms lift his legs and we'll get
him down the steps careful how you go
between the two of them they maneuvered
the body of Aras Kent down from the
gallows and onto the waiting cart
Peter the driver turned to look poor
bastard
he said in his gruff low Dutch yes well
justice is Swift Johannes pulled a
handkerchief from an upper pocket and
wiped at his fingers Hendrik patted the
horse on the flank the animal nickers
and breathed icy crystals from its
nostrils Johannes had just begun to
climb onto the cart for the ride back to
the Anatomy theatre when he saw a light
several hundred yards away
swinging slightly and coming closer it
appeared to be a lantern this was
confirmed when Johannes heard footsteps
on the cobblestones a moment later he
stepped back off the cart in motion for
Peter to wait
ho there a cloaked man approached his
arm raised in greeting his shuffling
gait and pained movement suggested an
old man but Johannes could not yet see
his face his dark figure made an eerie
apparition in the flickering pool of
lantern light Johannes raised a hand in
return is there something you need good
sir
the man limped toward them pushing back
the hood of his cloak his head was
massive and misshapen and nearly bald
aside from a few gray wisps his face was
a rough mass of wrinkles as though it
had been hewn out of soft wood forgive
me for interrupting your work gentlemen
he said nodding to each of them in turn
if I'm correct you're taking master Kent
to the surgeons guild for dissection you
are correct
Johannes replied the horse whinny din
clapped its hooves behind him eager to
be on its way and may I ask what you
will do with master Kent after the
dissection is completed the man held the
lantern closer to his face his eyes had
once been blue but were now filmed over
with cataracts Johannes frowned why do
you ask this a favor sir if I may ask
the man cackles his mouth splitting like
a rotted fruit his teeth like blackened
stalactites if your good self has no
more use for master Kent sir then might
I be allowed to take possession of him
afterward I mean his expression was odd
sycophantic and sly all at once his
milky eyes twinkled johannes crossed his
arms certainly not when ever makes you
request such a thing he could hear
Hendrick and Peter muttering darkly
behind him I can pay from among the
folds of his cloak that man produced a
small cloth bag that jingled pitifully
not much sirs I'm not a rich man but a
few golden for something you'll have no
further need of Johannes side the cold
was beginning to get to him his coat was
not as heavy as it could have been and
his uncovered fingers were beginning to
go numb did you know rs Kent was he a
relative of yours my son yes the man
still held the bag of money out in front
of him surely you can't refuse a father
taking the last remains of his son when
you are finished with them surely not
sir
he shook the bag making its contents
clink the sound suddenly seemed loud as
did the slow lapping of the nearby canal
Johannes glanced back at his helpers
their brows were knitted suspiciously
Hendrik pulled at the canvas that
covered the body then thrust his chin
out Johannes turned back to Kent's
alleged father
keep your money old man he spat if
you're so keen on having him that I
suppose it can't do any harm although
I'd prefer it if you kept the
transaction to yourself
of course sir I understand the Glee on
the man's face was horrible to see
distorting his features into something
resembling a gargoyles he tucked the
money back into his cloak and when may I
come to the anatomy theater at just past
sundown tomorrow Johannes said do you
know the alley that runs parallel with
neumarkt yes sir come that way to the
back of des Vosges there is a large gray
door bring your cart there and wait
until I come for you and try not to be
seen the old man pulled his hood back
over his face and gave a little bow
thank you sir he said his eyes nearly
whitened the glow from the flame I will
be waiting
he turned slowly on his heel and
shuffled off into the night the yellow
light from his Lantern throwing his
hunched shadow across the cobblestones
his jaw set Johannes checked the body
again securing the canvas with rope
without a word he climbed onto the cart
and motion for Peter to drive
ordinarily began dr. Tulp gripping the
forceps in his right hand we would begin
with the study of the viscera but today
I wanted to point out an item of
particular interest to me you will
notice I have made the incision here he
indicated the arm of the pale corpse of
Aras Kent and this he said lifting a
muscle carefully from the arm with the
forceps
is the flexor digitorum superficialis he
pulled that the muscle with the forceps
causing the corpses fingers to flex then
he demonstrated the motion with his own
hand at that point the observers crowded
more closely around and Johannes could
no longer see what was happening this
did not bother him he had witnessed many
of dr. Holt's lessons instead he stood
back and surveyed the crowd in the
anatomy theater it was the usual
collection of wealthy merchants and the
cream of Amsterdam society all dressed
in solemn black for the occasion they're
white ruffs crisp in the dimness near
the front though Johanna spotted a lone
figure clad and scruffy brown robes many
years out of fashion with a broad
working man's face and reddish hair
curling around his ears the man had a
sketchbook and was taking in the scene
with great intensity johannes thought
this must be that artists from Leyden
that he'd heard so much about dr. Tulp
had mentioned commissioning a group
portrait though johannes wasn't certain
what kind of portrait this young
scallywag would be able to produce still
master Van Ryn did have a sterling
reputation
despite his tender age and had come at
the recommendation of Constantin Huygens
himself so Johannes supposed his doubts
were likely groundless the artists rough
appearance vexed him though the man
stood out like an elephant in a field of
tulips dr. Tulp continued his dissection
his voice becoming a sing-song of
meaningless sounds to johannes his ears
the prepper a turd evaded his attention
between the crowd surrounding the corpse
and the earnest face of the artist who
was sketching madly when he wasn't
engrossed in the spectacle
as the day wore on Johannes began to
feel warm and uncomfortable despite the
deep chill that pervaded the theater he
never should have promised that cadaver
to that old man what if someone saw him
he could lose his position even be
charged with grave robbing the subjects
of the annual dissections were supposed
to be handed over to the secular
authorities for disposal
no executed criminal could be interred
and hallowed ground he wondered if that
was what Kent's father proposed to do
weasel his son into an undeserved
Christian burial Johannes squared his
shoulders he wasn't going to allow it
when the old man came for the body he
would tell him to go away better still
he would tell him that the authorities
had already come to claim the remains
the preparators smiled to himself his
discomfort easing yes everything would
be all right when doctor told had
finished his dissection in the crowd had
started to disperse Johannes stepped
forward to remove the body from the
operating area the incisions on the
corpse had been stitched closed to keep
the organs from spilling out during
transport but the cut in the arm was
still open and flapped redly johannes
curled his lip and placed the arm across
the man's sunken chest hiding the worst
of the wound he glanced up and noticed
that dr. Tulp had crossed the theater
and was now deep in conversation with
the scruffy-looking artist peering at
the sketches and nodding approvingly
grunting with the effort Johannes pushed
the body on its wheeled wooden cart to
the preparation room behind the main
chamber the preparators could still hear
buzzing voices from without but
thankfully this back room was empty he
pushed the cart up against the wall
averting his gaze from Arras Kent's
naked bluish carcass it had started to
rot despite the freezing weather and
Johannes could just catch a whiff of
decay when he turned his head
through the high narrow windows the Sun
was blazing orange it was nearly sunset
he looked around the room critically he
would have to hide the corpse if he
didn't want to give it to the old man
but where the preparation room was small
and cramped with sturdy wooden tables
lining the stone walls there was a tall
cabinet in the corner that afforded
possibilities but when johannes opened
it he found that it was already packed
tight with instruments and supplies he
muttered under his breath wishing he'd
done a better job of keeping the area
free of clutter well it was too late to
bemoan his poor housekeeping the old man
would be arriving soon and the body had
to be gone moving as swiftly as his
gangly frame would allow Johannes pulled
a length of canvas from under one of the
tables and threw it over Kent's body
tucking the loose ends underneath his
slack limbs then he wrapped the grisly
package with four lengths of rope
keeping the knots fairly loose so they
didn't sink into the flesh that done he
lifted the body from the cart holding it
against him as if he was waltzing with
it the smell this close was nauseating
even though he was used to dealing with
corpses he dragged Kint across the room
heading for the back door he wished he
had thought to bring his own cart around
but someone might have seen him and
wondered what he was up to in any case
he could hide the body in the rubbish
piles behind a vibe and then bring his
cart around after darkness fell from
there he would take it to the
authorities dropping it anonymously in
front of the building if need be his
back aching with the strain Johannes
undid the latch on the back door and
prepared to push it open it was at that
moment that someone knocked softly but
definitively
before the door had even opened Willem
Kent knew something was amiss he could
hear a distinct grunt and then the sound
of rapid footsteps and large furniture
being shifted around he smiled his
milk-white eyes gleaming
so the preparators was planning to go
back on their agreement no matter he had
suspected as much
the old man reached into his cloak and
fingered the haft of the silver dagger
he kept there then he reached up and
knocked again at last the gray door
swung open and the preparators stood
there looking flustered and sweaty in a
dour black waistcoat with one button
missing the old man bowed I've come as
you asked sir he said in his most
deferential tone and I have kept myself
unseen ah so here you are
the preparators foot tapped on the stone
and he stared down at the old man as if
he didn't really see him yes well I'm
afraid there's been a bit of confusion
confusion sir Willem had taken the knife
from its leather pouch he held it in one
hand concealed by a long sleeve yes the
authorities you see the ones who
normally take possession of the bodies
well they have the preparators last over
his shoulder they've already come it's
most unusual and I'm sorry that I cannot
honor our agreement the old man smiled
and bowed his head it certainly isn't
any fault of yours sir he said then he
arranged his face to suggest sorrow I
would have liked to see my boy at least
once more though sir even though he was
a thief and a brute he was still my son
well I do apologize
the preparators fingers twitch on the
door latch you did what she could sir
and I do thank you Willem held out his
hand the one that didn't contain the
dagger I'll not trouble you again the
relief was visible on the preparators
face he reached out to grasp the old
man's hand
with speed and agility shocking and a
man so ancient willem clasped the
preparators hand and pulled the younger
man down toward him simultaneously
slicing upward with the dagger and
connecting with the flesh of the
preparators chest the flow of blood was
immediate and hot while the younger man
was still reeling from the attack
Willem threw him to the ground and
stepped over his writhing body into the
preparation room the area was small and
Willem could see immediately where the
corpse lay crammed haphazardly beneath
one of the big wooden tables his sandals
slapping on the stones he crossed the
room and knelt to drag the body free he
had been outside to fog for a while
watching the comings and goings he knew
most of the observers had gone but a few
still lingered so he would have to work
quickly
the preparators owned but not loudly
Willem ignored him focused on his task
Aris kins had been a thin man in life
but in death he seemed to have gained
several pounds the old man struggled
mightily pulling his canvas wrapped
burden across the floor his cart was
just outside in the alley he didn't have
far to go as he stepped past the
preparators
the younger man reached out and grabbed
his ankle but the grip was weak the man
was dying
Willem shook his hand off and bent down
to lift the corpse at last after much
effort the old man had succeeded at
getting Aras onto his cart it was now
full dark outside and the road around
Dave Aude was deserted
before he mounted behind the horse
Willem used his foot to push the
preparators limp body back into the
building closing the door on it with a
massive heave
there was a thick pool of blood cooling
on the stones but the old man didn't
think anyone would notice it until
morning his clothes were another matter
but he couldn't worry about that just
now nodding to himself he climbed onto
his cart and urged his horse forward
when he finally slowed he had come
nearly two miles from the center of
Amsterdam and was in one of the worst
sections of the city the houses were
caked with filth half-naked ragamuffins
ran the streets at all hours of the
night the only buildings with lanterns
burning were the pubs which spilled
noise and drunken revelers into the
crooked narrow alleys Willem had not lit
his lantern on the journey here in order
to keep a lower profile now he was glad
he had not he travelled in darkness
keeping to the shadows avoiding the few
shady figures he spotted walking along
the open and refuse clotted sewers he
finally arrived at a great boardinghouse
which had a torch burning above the door
he drew his cart even with the entrance
and climbed down from his perch he
thought he could smell the fetid odor
coming off heiresses corpse but it might
have been sewage or any number of other
horrible things that willem didn't care
to imagine there was a long silence
after he'd knocked at the door for a
moment his heart dropped thinking the
woman was not here had forgotten their
appointment then he heard the Clank of a
metal key in the lock and the door
opened a crack a yellow dye peered out
at him brought it have you a voice
croaked Willem gestured to the cart in
lieu of answering
the door opened wider revealing a small
hunched woman dressed in several layers
of ragged wool shawls her long white
hair was gnarled and tangled emerging
wildly from beneath a faded red cloth
wrapped around her head she raised a
wizened hand and beckoned with one
skeletal finger will own lifted the
corpse from the cart still wrapped in
its canvas shroud the woman stepped back
and let him carry it into the front room
of the boardinghouse which was lit by a
single Lantern and contained no
furniture except a single wooden chair
and a battered cooking pot sitting on a
hearth that looked as though it hadn't
been lit in quite some time as there was
nowhere to put the body down the old man
simply laid it gently on the floor
the stones were as cold as ice he could
feel them through his thin shoes you pay
the woman was standing directly behind
him
her breath rattling and stinking of old
meat her hand was extended like the
clobber bird of prey Willem dug in his
cloak and produced his cloth bag it only
held a few golden all that he possessed
in the world he shook the coins into the
woman's hand she stared at them as
though they represented the riches of a
sultan a moment later she had Secret of
them somewhere amid her shawls you wait
upstairs she commanded pointing to a
rickety ladder in the corner that Willem
had not noticed am I not to witness it
then he asked drawing himself up to full
height no I must do alone you may come
down after she chewed at her lips with
her blackened gums
go now I call for you when it is
finished defeated Willem glanced once
more at the body of his son nearly
shapeless under the canvas and made his
way toward the ladder
dr. Nikolai's toll ascended the stairs
at de fog up to the living quarters
above the Anatomy theater master Van Ryn
the painter had been staying there for
the past few days while he worked on the
Commission but this was the first time
that dr. Tulp had gone up to check on
his progress he had heard that Rembrandt
worked quickly so he hoped there would
be some substantial progress to see he
knocked discreetly and at Rembrandt's
call he entered the room was small but
pleasant with a large window looking out
at the nieuwmarkt which was bustling at
this time of day Rembrandt himself stood
before his canvas a brush in his mouth
his diminutive frame draped in his
trademark brown robes he looked dr. Tulp
thought with some amusement like a
particularly unkempt monk as he watched
the painter leaned forward and scraped
at the canvas with the end of his brush
handle good day master van Rijn dr. Tulp
hailed removing his round crowd hat an
emblem of his status I hope I'm not
interrupting anything but I was curious
to see how you were coming along I'd be
honored sir
Rembrandt said with a little bow backing
away from the painting so that dr. Tulp
would ever closer look at it why this is
extraordinary dr. Tulp leaned close his
nose almost touching the canvas the
composition is most wonderful I've never
seen another like it thank you for
saying so sir I did wish to capture a
certain movement in addition to focusing
attention on your good self sir well
you've certainly done that dr. Tulp said
obviously pleased you've worked on this
a great deal I see it looks almost
finished yes it does need some more work
in some areas such as here on the arm of
the corpse my sketches of it were not as
detailed as they could have been I fear
perhaps distance was a factor there sir
Rembrandt had picked up another brush
and was drawing the stiff bristles
between his fingers well I have plenty
of anatomical tacks if you need a
reference there in my study just down
the hall there you may borrow them
anytime you like the doors never locked
thank you sir that would be most helpful
indeed dr. Tulp took one last appraising
glance at the painting and then turned
to leave placing his hat back upon his
head I must say that I'm happy that
master Huygens recommended you for this
position I think this work will be a
credit to you as well as to me in my
profession I hope so sir
Rembrandt bowed again his brush still in
his hand his robes spattered with paint
good day then dr. Tulp stepped over the
threshold then remembered something and
turned back I say master van Rijn did
you hear that awful business last night
in the lightest rot the murder
Rembrandt looked up startled no who was
murdered damned if I can remember his
name main executioner he was ironic that
isn't it he chuckled a little and
coughed well not safe to walk the
streets at night sad to say in any case
I'm sure the person responsible would be
brought to justice in the meantime he
tipped his hat with his hand again good
day master van Rijn good day sir
dr. Taub left the studio and closed the
door quietly behind him Willem Kent
sat in the rooms only chair and stared
at his son in the flickering lamplight
he could hardly believe what the woman
had done even now 24 hours later
aras was slumped against the far wall
his eyes glazed but open and presumably
seeing his weight fingers beating a
nervous rhythm on the knees of his
tattered trousers he didn't appear to be
breathing but he lived by hell the old
man crossed himself knowing that this
small piety could not atone for the
abomination he had wrought tonight again
said the woman who was bent over the
hearth stirring an evil smelling broth
in her cooking pot yes Willem said the
executioner is dead tonight he will
revenge himself upon the sheriff who
convicted him and perhaps upon the man
who fingered him for the crime if he can
find him the woman cackles your son will
live until his revenge is complete no
matter how long it may take
yes I understand that Willem said Aras
was looking dumbly back and forth
between his father and the old woman
understanding little or nothing
Willems heartbroke seeing his sons
emotionless face hanging there in the
dimness this was not his son resurrected
as much as he would have liked to think
so
it was merely a body animated by
bloodlust by a rough kind of Justice
Willam peered through the window and saw
the moon full and orange floating above
the horizon soon he thought to himself
the woman poured her reeking concoction
into two bowls and handed one to Willem
he held his breath and sipped trying not
to gag it didn't taste as bad as it
smelled but that wasn't seeing a great
deal
he considered taking the bowl to Aris to
feed him but he already knew it would be
pointless the thing that Aris had become
was no longer human and no longer needed
human nourishment when the soup was gone
and the lantern had burnt down a little
further Aris began to stir getting
clumsily to his feet as though he was a
marionette on a string Willem stood also
keeping well back the woman had said
that these specimens were sometimes
erratic and might turn on those who were
helping them Aris though seemed not to
notice his father at all and instead
turned his head toward the door making
his way toward it with deliberate
shuffling steps
the woman nodded and Willem began to
follow keeping a safe distance
once they were away from the house
Willem stepped up his pace trailing RS
by about six feet the streets were dark
but the moon provided ample light and
Willem had no trouble keeping his
ghostly son in view the night before
Aris had headed westward leader strata
tonight he turned East trudging along
with the single-minded purpose the city
seemed silent around them the sound of
the corpses footfalls on the
cobblestones was blasphemous the old man
struggled to keep up over the long trek
Aris was tireless and kept a constant
pace the moon had risen farther in the
sky by the time they turned into a wide
avenue lined with respectable houses
lamps blazed on every corner but the
street was eerily devoid of life Aris
mounted the steps of a particularly fine
house with whitewashed shutters and
stone lions flanking the entrance the
door was dark green and had a gold
knocker Aris however did not knock but
simply opened the door and stepped
inside
Willem as he had done on the previous
night waited outside in the street
pulling his cloak around him to fend off
the cold he heard the sounds as much as
he wanted to stop his ears he would not
because he knew he must participate in
some small way he must accept a modicum
of responsibility he told himself that
the sheriff was getting what he deserved
he had executed an innocent man after
all as true as this was it did not make
hearing the sounds of his death and
easier it seemed both an eternity and a
matter of seconds before Aris emerged
from the house his hastily assembled
clothes since he'd come from the anatomy
theater naked soaked with red his face
was as slack and emotionless as ever his
eyes like two silver coins glinting in
the night the noises the sheriff had
made and dying had apparently awakened
others Willem could see candles being
lit in windows around the street his
heart hammering in his chest he gestured
for Aris to hurry not having any idea if
his son could understand him
as they made their way up the Avenue and
back into the darkness he thought he
could hear shouting and barking dogs he
quickened his pace to a trot which was
as fast as his bones would move these
days Aras was still a few steps behind
but he caught up easily and passed his
father looping along as though he hadn't
a care in the world
Willem hopes that the one murder would
be enough for one evening
but this hope was dashed when Aras
turned not toward the boardinghouse but
south toward the Moretz Cod his legs
aching will him followed
the second man was drinking at a pub
nearly half a mile from the sheriff's
house Aras stood outside and stared in
with his strange stupid gaze his black
hair falling limply across his forehead
Willem stood in the shadows a few yards
away shivering and his thin cloak he
didn't know how long they would have to
wait but the old man hoped it wasn't
long enough for him to freeze to death
fortunately it was no more than half an
hour before the man staggered out alone
into the darkened alley beside the pub
he burped then laughed loudly before
bracing himself against the wall with
one hand his piss steamed is it
spattered on to the stones he sang a
snatch of song nearly fell pissing on
his shoes in the process then righted
himself willem was almost glad to see
the man in this state at least he
wouldn't comprehend what was happening
to him iris approached from behind and
he was nearly upon his victim before the
drunken man turned he didn't seem
surprised in the least but murmured
something that sounded vaguely
companionable Aras reached for him and
closed a long thin hand around the man's
neck the drunks eyes got bigger and he
opened his mouth to protest but all that
came out was a beer smelling belch Aras
squeezed and Willem heard something pop
the man fell to the ground groaning Aras
bent over him like a vulture his
claw-like hands tearing at his clothes
and skin the man's cries grew weaker and
weaker as Aras leaned closer and closer
going at the man with fingers and teeth
at some point ours must have severed an
artery because blood sprayed against the
alley wall mingling with the cooling
urine and producing a noxious aroma of
copper and ammonia Willem turned away
but he could still hear the wet sounds
of flesh being torn from bone the sounds
of bones being crushed by teeth the
sounds from the pub seemed far away part
of another world when ours had finished
there was little left of the man but
blood and a pile of shredded rags
smeared here and there with gobbets of
skin and fat willem fought the urge to
vomit stepping out of the polluted alley
and breathing deeply of the frigid night
air somehow his own killing of that
officious preparators
had not bothered the old man nearly as
much as seeing the same crime
perpetrated by his only son he wasn't
sure why this should be
but he couldn't deny it iris appeared a
moment later looking like a parody of a
painted devil crimson from head to toe
sighing Willem removed his topmost cloak
and threw it over his son's shoulders
the boy's face was still a fright but
perhaps no one would notice in the dark
his teeth chattering the old man
followed as the corpse shambled in a
northerly direction back toward the
boardinghouse
the three murders had been carried out
justice had been served
Willem was saddened by the fact that his
son would now be well and truly lost to
him while it was true that this mute
monstrosity before him was no
replacement for the real living Aras the
corpse still bore his son's outer
trappings and this Willem reasoned was
enough to stir sentimental feelings
within him when morning came he thought
he would lay Aris Kent to rest with the
knowledge that he had avenged his
wrongful execution and may God forgive
him for that
the moon had passed the halfway point in
the firmament meaning dawn was but a few
short hours away the cold was like many
tiny knives biting into his flesh and
the walk had all been exhausted every
ounce of energy he possessed he would be
glad to get back to the boardinghouse
even glad to sip at a bowl of the
woman's fowl stew the house was surely
not far now but it seemed that Aris was
not walking toward the boarding house
after all he had turned again this time
to the northwest toward the center of
Amsterdam as soon as the old man
realized this his heart began something
again there was no one else responsible
for the execution he was certain of it
and the woman had promised that Aras
would only live as long as it took to
take revenge on those responsible for
his death so what was happening now
Willem went after him mystified
forgetting about his tired legs and his
frozen fingers Aras seemed as
unconcerned as ever moving deliberately
along the streets not feeling the cold
at all before long the old man thought
he could hear the lap of the canal in
the distance moments later a large stone
building that looked like a fortress
loomed before them without pausing to
look or consider Aras made his
meandering way toward it and Willem
hurried to follow Rembrandt had been
sleeping but woke when he thought he
heard a noise on the stairs outside his
room he lay on his cot straining to hear
no one else was supposed to be in the
building at this time of night normally
he didn't mind the solitude but the
stories about the murder had stoked his
already active imagination
he had almost decided that the sound had
been a mouse and that he should try to
go back to sleep when it came again a
dragging furtive sound definitely made
by something much larger than a rodent
he sat up and felt for his cloak the
moonlight was streaming in the window
providing just enough light to make his
easel look like a hulking beast with
spindly legs he pulled his cloak around
himself and lit the lantern on the table
near the cot the room appeared as
ordinary as it had been when he'd
retired to bed but now the sound was
louder a scraping right outside the door
frightened he lifted the lantern and
crept across the room
who's there he called there was no
answer but then he thought he heard a
knock I'll be at one that sounded
somehow meaty and damp he shuddered who
is it there came another sound labored
breathing and a quick patter of
footsteps I'm sorry to disturb you sir
I'm not sure why we've come relieved to
hear a human voice at last
Rembrandt approached the door lantern in
hand and opened it for a moment he
didn't understand what he was seeing and
when he did he nearly dropped the
lantern what the devil
sorry again sir an old man in wooly
inadequate clothing appeared behind the
horror that stood swaying upon the
doorstep this is my son
I suppose he wishes to see you Rembrandt
stepped back into the room glad to move
away from the thin pale monster who
appeared to be covered in blood and he
smelled like a slaughterhouse the old
man came into the room first worming his
way around the younger man who didn't
move from the threshold after a long
moment he staggered into the room the
old man closed the door behind him
Rembrandt had nothing in the way of
refreshment to offer the pair so simply
motion for them to sit on the cot he had
recently vacated the old man sat wearily
but the Sun just stood his shoulders
slumped his gaze seemed to be fixed upon
the painting that Rembrandt had nearly
completed the one that he hoped would
make his fortune in Amsterdam as the
artist watched the savage looking man
hobbled over to the canvas and stopped a
few feet in front of it
tilting his head to one side he won't
damage it Willie
Rembrandt whispered but the old man just
shrugged and shook his head The Silence
of the room was broken only by the harsh
rasp of the old man's breathing at last
the younger man stirred and turned away
from the painting for a brief second
understanding seemed a flicker in his
silver coin eyes and he stared at
Rembrandt as though trying to remember
where he might have seen him before the
artist felt his blood run cold at the
scrutiny when the man moved
Rembrandt stepped back his arms half
raised to ward off an attack but the
monster simply shuffled forward and sat
at the table that served his Rembrandt's
dining area he then flopped his pale arm
onto the wooden tabletop letting the
incision made by dr. Nikolai's tope flap
open exposing the muscles and nerves
beneath the artist gasped recognizing
the wound immediately surely this could
not be the same man he had witnessed on
the dissection table just a few short
days before as he studied the features
the low heavy brow the slightly upturned
nose the scruff of beard at the chin he
knew for certain that this man had been
the unwitting model at the center of his
latest painting the anatomy lesson of
dr. Nikolai's taupe
the man was sitting still as though
waiting for something the wound on his
arm still looked fresh and Rembrandt
remembered how dr. Tulp had pulled at
the flexor digitorum superficialis with
his forceps causing the corpses fingers
to flex Rembrandt had made several
sketches of the action but he hadn't
been able to get it exactly right it was
this that was holding up the
satisfactory completion of the painting
then understanding dawned moving as
quickly as he could he lit the remaining
three lanterns in the room the light was
far from adequate but it would have to
do he pulled his easel closer to the
table and added linseed oil to the
pigments he'd ground before going to bed
is this right he wanted to ask the dead
man but he knew it was so he didn't ask
loading his brush with red lake he began
laying in the detail on the corpses arm
sketching in the muscles with long thick
strokes then going back over them with
more refined movements as he worked he
heard the old man come up behind him his
breath warm on the artists neck he
pointed at the canvas that's my boy
there the old man said it was almost a
sigh yes it was all Rembrandt could say
there were so many questions he wanted
to ask the old man about what had
happened but he dared not speak them out
loud one did not question a miracle just
before the moon set behind the horizon
Rembrandt stood back and surveyed his
painting a smile creeping across his
ample face the muscles of our skins arm
now lay exposed in glimmering and
perfect laid open forever for the entire
world to see the old man leaned in and
reach toward the image his fingers
trembling just inches away from its
surface and then he brought his fingers
to his lips and held them there
Rembrandt thought he saw tears sparkling
in the old man's eyes it is finished the
artist directed this statement to RS
Kent who still sat at the table as
though he would never move his face as
blank as the face of a Greek statue he
did not look at the painting but simply
lifted his arm from the tabletop then
rose from his chair it was time for him
to go
the old men clasped a Rembrandt's arm
somehow he remembered it was all he
could manage but it was all that was
necessary
Rembrandt nodded his head not speaking
but saying volumes with his silence the
dead man and his devoted father made a
bedraggled parade toward the door of
Rembrandt's temporary studio the old man
opened the door and let his son walk out
before him then he turned thank you sir
he said he seemed to remember something
then for his face went distant and
melancholy but the emotion was gone in
an instant he bowed his bald head and
then disappeared into the shadows of the
outer Hall
Rembrandt stood and watched the door for
a long time after they had gone he
glanced at his painting again
ara skin's body seemed to glow with a
kind of inner light a humanity that
emanated from him making him more than
just a corpse being dissected upon a
slab Rembrandt laughed a little sadly
dr. Taub would likely view himself as
the star attraction of this portrait but
the artist would always know where its
true heart lay
I suppose that I was technically dead
before I hit the ground although I can't
say that for sure I don't know exactly
when the line between life and death was
crossed and perhaps I never will but the
funny thing was that even though I had
died was in the past tense as it were I
still managed to feel the impact of my
bloody sack of flesh against the
floorboards hear the thump that was
muffled by an inch of brown shag
carpeting scarier yet I could see Saleem
standing over me with the smeared and
sparkling blade sprouting from her paper
white fist her mouth was twisted her
chest heaved the blood on the knife
perfectly matched the twin scarlet
blotches that stained her otherwise
colorless cheeks like Rorschach inkblots
Saleem was staring at me and I felt it
unwise to alert her to my peculiar
condition she had plunged that
pig-sticker right into my throat after
all and had every right to expect me to
have shuffled off my mortal coil
who knew whether another good stab
wouldn't finish the job
I lay perfectly still my eyeballs were
drying out when she looked away for a
second I blinked and then glanced am i
right the golden vial winked seductively
just millimeters from my fingers it must
have dropped and rolled as I fell
Celine's eagle eyes rested on me again
and I froze she swooped down from her
great height and snatched the vial up in
her hand I could smell her familiar
aroma as she parted the air above me all
lilies and apples and the vague musk of
adrenaline she gave the vial a cursory
once-over then replaced the cap and
secretin it in her pocket my heart sank
it must have been the blood of course
not my blood but the blood in the vial I
didn't think any of it had passed my
lips but a drop of it must have somehow
before saline had come howling into the
room like a bladed banshee it was the
blood that had kept me alive even as my
own bread lifeforce spurted in great
dark fountains from the wound in my neck
I almost laughed
it really works I thought all that time
when I thought Celine was just kidding
around or crazy or both I tried to
remain still a thousand thoughts were
stumbling through my head tripping over
one another why hadn't I believed her
sooner why hadn't I waited until she was
out and then thundering into my brain
and big neon letters as red as the blood
I have to drink the rest yes I would
have to for if the molecule of that
magical elixir that I had swallowed
could do this imagine what drinking the
entire vial would do I tried to be still
but my whole body was vibrating I had to
plan Celine was standing there like
stone she was thinking of what she was
going to do with me I had to act fast I
decided if I moved quickly unexpectedly
I could use her few seconds of surprise
to my advantage
resting knife and vial from her
precarious possession I didn't know if I
would be able to best her not in this
condition but I had to try i bunched my
muscles to spring Celine turned sharply
and left the room my muscles relaxed
[ __ ] where is she going I could hear her
white pumps pounding down the stairs
hear the door from the kitchen to the
garage opening and closing I stayed put
playing possum my heart would have been
racing if it hadn't stopped beating
altogether the carpet around me was a
mushy soup of gore I tried to ignore the
uncomfortable squish beneath my back in
arms when Celine reappeared at the
threshold of the bedroom her cheeks were
red ur than ever and her eyes glittered
like a Wolverines I know it sounds
stupid but I still loved her she was
beautiful there framed in the doorway
everything about her was white white
dress white skin and that peculiar
silvery hair that always reminded me of
fine spider silk an avenging angel I
thought then I looked down Celine's hand
to the one that had conveyed the life
ending blow was now encircling the
pockmarked handle of the axe from the
garage her other hand clutched a roll of
black garbage bags I nearly screamed
what the [ __ ] was I supposed to do now
lie here and let her chop me to pieces
she positioned herself over me bringing
the ax up over her head hefting its
weight in both of her delicate hands
and that was when I struck she was
startled that much was obvious my body
sprang from the floor like a bloody
jack-in-the-box grabbing at her
whiteness with scarlet fingers she
shrieked and jumped back almost falling
but catching herself the axe split the
atoms just above my head I'm sure I
heard the hairs there cry out in mortal
terror i staggered to my feet reaching
for her I felt weak and ill but not as
bad as I expected all things considered
Selene backed up a step her shock had
morphed into fury I could see it in the
set of her jaw she meant to finish me
this woman I had loved for more than
five years I told you James she said her
voice tight but otherwise as pleasant as
ever
why didn't she listen to me give me the
vial I said I walked toward her with my
arms outstretched a shambling
Frankenstein's monster I can't do that
she said she swung the axe again
I ducked clumsily but it caught me on
the ear I felt nothing and I didn't have
any blood left in my body to gush forth
from the wound
I kept shuffling toward her you've
already ruined everything for me she
said you already drank some of the blood
I can't leave you like this
it has to be finished you can't kill me
I said I didn't know that for certain
but I said it with defiance I can and I
will she hissed although she didn't look
so sure of herself she doesn't even know
I thought some almighty keeper of
ancient wisdom she turned out to be I
swiped at her clawing at the pocket that
held the life-giving fluid but she was
ready for me
stepping back she brought the axe down
full upon my left shoulder nearly
severing the arm in one blow it didn't
hurt not really she swung the axe once
twice three times until both my arms lay
like grotesque flesh colored snakes upon
the carpet she's gonna have a lot of
cleaning up to do I thought crazily
without the use of my arms my body pin
wheeled off-balance and I crashed to the
floor on my side that was the only
opportunity Selene needed I had a brief
second where my entire field of vision
was annihilated by a huge silver blade
like an absurdly realistic 3d movie and
then I was looking at the rest of my
abused form from a few feet across the
floor I could see the ragged red
where my head and neck had parted
company you [ __ ] I tried to scream but
of course my severed vocal cords offered
nothing but an inaudible gurgle I tried
to give her a withering stare but it's
very difficult to look intimidating when
you're the same size shape and
usefulness as a roughed-up bowling ball
she looked at me she was sweating and
quite mad and seemingly enjoying herself
then she began hacking away at my legs
they proved a tougher job than the arms
had been but she eventually got them off
my body now lay scattered in six pieces
like an anatomical jigsaw and still I
lived Celine knelt down near my head
peering into my eyes I'm sorry about
this James she said as if she'd done
nothing more earth-shattering than
forgetting to pick up the dry-cleaning
you did bring it on yourself though fat
[ __ ] chance I wanted to say but my
moving lips produced no sound I mean
sure I had disobeyed her explicit
instructions and sure she had told me
time and time again that she would have
to kill me if I ever meddled in her
affairs but I'd never taken her
seriously my mouth snapped shut it was
no use making excuses now was it she
unfurled one of the garbage bags and
shoved a leg into it than the other and
then she did the same for my arms and
torso soon she had a small pile of bags
that would have appeared as innocuous as
lawn clippings if not for the
reddish-brown stains covering nearly
every square inch of the room finally
she unrolled the last bag goodbye James
she said and picked my poor head up by
the hair and dropped it in with a swish
everything was dark for a little while
a short time later I felt the rumble of
a motor beneath my cheek waking me from
a fitful doze I couldn't see a damn
thing but I deduced that I was in the
spotless trunk of Celine's pearl gray
Oldsmobile I felt yielding flesh around
me an elbow poking out here a couple of
toes there all my worldly parts in a
neat little pile beneath my head like a
pillow what the hell is going to become
of me I wondered will I live forever in
this pitiful state what a depressing
thought it was hot in the trunk and
sweat started trickling into my eyes of
course I couldn't wipe it away all I
could do is blink and grit my teeth at
the rotten injustice of it all the
rumble of the motor stopped and the
darkness suddenly lifted I could see a
kind of diffuse glow through the plastic
Selene had opened the trunk she was
rooting around in the body parts as if
she was picking out produce I wondered
if I could bite her but she was too
quick she pulled free one of the bags it
looked small maybe one of the arms then
slammed the trunk engulfing me in
blackness again after a few moments I'm
quite sure I heard a splashing noise so
that's her game I thought distributing
my wretched piece is far and wide trying
to cover her tracks well let her
I'll get that vial somehow I don't know
why I was so sure but I was as I rode
along I thought of Selene of how I was
going to get her back in a way even
though it sounds bizarre I didn't blame
her for all this she had to her credit
told me about the vial from the very
beginning I hadn't believed her of
course who would have when a person
tells you that she is the latest in a
long line of guardians of the blood of
the great god Osiris and that the blood
has the power to resurrect to the dead
just as Osiris himself was resurrected
by Isis well you tend to think that
person might have a screw loose
somewhere and yet all through our 5
years of marriage that file was always
at the back of my mind I'd be lying if I
said it wasn't it was stupid of course
it couldn't possibly do what Saleem
claimed but still my curiosity had grown
with each passing year and in the end
just like one of Bluebeard's ill-fated
Brides I gave into it with fatal results
I would have side if my windpipe had
still been connected to my lungs
a few miles later another body part was
retrieved and discarded and a few miles
later another sometimes I heard a splash
and sometimes I heard a metallic bang
like something heavy hitting the bottom
of a dumpster soon my head was all that
was left of me in the trunk and after a
while when it had presumably grown dark
outside I could no longer see any light
through the sheet of my plastic prison I
felt my head being lifted from the damp
carpeting and cradled in saline slim
arms was that tenderness she was
handling me with or was it just my
imagination I opened my mouth and bared
my teeth but I couldn't turn to grab her
she held me too tightly all I got was a
mouthful of plastic for my pains and
then came a sensation that I'm sure no
living person has ever experienced there
was a strangely exhilarating feeling of
flight as my head was hurled through the
air unattached and free I felt
weightless then came a sharp slap as I
hit the surface of the water
I sank and even though the water pressed
in around me I found I could still
breathe and felt no discomfort that was
something at least the lake or whatever
it was wasn't very deep because I
settled at the bottom almost immediately
the soft sand receiving my next stump
like a nest receives an egg it was very
quiet I still couldn't see but soon I
began to feel tiny nips at the plastic
as if many small fish were investigating
me checking to see if I was worth eating
it tickled and I tried to move to
frighten them away but I couldn't I just
blinked in the silence what now
I don't know how much time passed the
damn fish had had their way with me
nibbling through the plastic so that I
could now see through it in places the
water was dirty peppered with pieces of
bag and flesh I had pretty much come to
terms with the fact that I was just
going to sit here and be eaten by fish
until the end of time or until someone
found my head whichever came first but
then something wonderful happened it was
morning I knew that because of the way
the sunlight shimmered on the surface of
the water filtering down among the
ripples I awoke to the usual gang of
fish faces staring back at me with their
weird unblinking eyes their little
mouths opening and closing in perfect
unison as though they were singing a
hymn I farad my brow at them which was
all I could do and which naturally had
no effect on them at all and then I
heard something moving something big all
the muscles in my head stiffened the
first thing that sprang to mind was an
alligator the ornery reptiles were not
unknown in these parts I felt less than
enthusiastic about finding out what it
might be like to live in the belly of
one of the beasts even for the few days
it would take him to digest me I
struggled to move to roll to one side
anything but as ever
I was stuck fast buried to the chin and
shifting layers of silt and mud I closed
my eyes please let him think I'm a rock
I thought the big thing was coming
closer moving the water in great
undulating waves disturbing the lake
bottom I couldn't stand it any more I
opened my eyes the fish were gone and
sitting there right in front of me
dabbled in the early morning sunlight
was my torso it looked not much the
worse for wear just a few patches of
skin missing here and there it couldn't
have been in the water it had likely
been one of the lucky pieces to be
consigned to dumpster land its sat there
the empty next up seeming to consider me
as though struggling to recognize a
distant relative and then it inched
closer and I found my head was moving of
its own accord digging itself out of the
mud my eyes rolled wildly and my mouth
flapped open and closed in an impression
of one of the fish my head was sliding
towards my body and then I realized that
the blood must have been doing this it
was bringing all my scattered parts back
together I was ecstatic my head and
torso met and fused I
like a madman it was only a few seconds
later that I noticed my other parts
crawling through the water toward me
like enormous sea slugs each approached
with trepidation and then sidled up to
fuse with the rest of me I can't begin
to describe the joy I felt some of the
pieces had fared better than others
though all were in various stages of
decay and all had black flecks of
plastic still attached my right arm
looks the worst the skin had gone gray
and bone was showing through in places
but that was all right when my body was
whole again I found I could move freely
with my rotted and damaged limbs just as
I had when I was alive and healthy
triumphantly i sat up in the water I
wanted to scream to the universe I had
cheated death I was immortal I got to my
feet the water was only up to my shins
the fish swam near me uncertainly and I
kicked them away with an enormous splash
giggling all the while I stood like that
for a few minutes before realizing that
I was of course naked is the day I was
born my clothes had fallen or been eaten
away well that was all right - I could
find something to wear I took stock of
my desiccated body preferably something
with long sleeves I thought and maybe a
hood
I ducked into some underbrush I had no
idea where I was nothing looked familiar
I could hear the rush of a highway
somewhere nearby but I couldn't see
anything other than trees and grass
clearings carefully I crawled out of the
bushes and peered around maybe if I
wasn't far from civilization someone
would come down to the water eventually
someone whose clothes I could steal as I
waited I became aware of a peculiar
sound it was a kind of faraway hum
sinuous and hypnotic under the roar of
the traffic I cocked my half-eaten ear
toward it it sounded like a voice
whispered but perfectly audible it was
calling me I was sure of it I couldn't
tell if it was a man's voice or a
woman's but not obeying the call was
apparently not an option my body began
moving of its own accord toward the
voice helpless I simply relaxed and let
my reattached limbs lead me where they
would
I'm not sure how far I walked strangely
no one seemed to notice my nudity or if
they did they didn't react to it the
streets were fairly lonely anyway with
what seemed like hours going by between
one car and the next I walked and walked
dropping little pieces of flesh along
the roadside leaving a trail like Hansel
and Gretel's breadcrumbs it got dark and
then light again and still I walked I
wasn't tired at all my bare feet didn't
even blister or chafe on the blacktop
it was growing dark again when I saw a
car pulled over to the side of the road
up ahead it was dusk and I squinted as I
approached it I was about a hundred feet
away when the realization dawned that
the car was familiar it was a pearl gray
Oldsmobile my jaw clenched the voice was
calling me toward it the blood was
calling me back to Selene she came out
of the woods I guess she'd gone in there
for a pee or something
she was pretty surprised to see me I
stopped just behind the car she stood
there staring
hello Selene I said it seemed
appropriate how did she find me she
asked she was edging toward the car as
she spoke don't know much about that
blood of yours do you I said she frowned
closer to the car closer I know enough
her hand met the car door felt for the
handle it called me I said it wants me
to drink the rest of it I have to have
the rest of it you don't want it James
she fumbled for her keys and I can't
give it to you I took a step toward her
I wasn't expecting you to give it to me
she got the door open then turned waving
the keys at me like a weapon get away
from me I lunged at her one of the keys
sunk into the soft flesh of my cheek I
just laughed my hands encircling her
arms she screamed but there was no one
around to hear her where is it I asked
she pressed her lips together closed her
eyes and shook her head she wasn't going
to tell me well it didn't matter
she still had it with her if that much I
was certain she was squirming and
punching at me with her useless fists
the song of the blood in my ears was
deafening
drowning out her screams finish her it
said my fingers crept up to her throat I
did feel a moment of regret as I snapped
her neck only a moment
her white form crumpled at my feet sorry
Celine I thought I kicked her aside and
climbed into the car I felt an immature
stab of Glee in the fact that I was
getting broad flesh all over the
pristine interior of her car I looked in
the glove compartment and there was the
vial right there on top of the
oldsmobile owner's manual I snorted
guardian of the blood of the great god
Osiris
way to go Celine I pulled the stopper
and drank the blood was warm and smooth
going down like hot chocolate with cream
it was singing my praises all the way
down to my stomach I licked my lips
rested back on the gray upholstery I
waited I didn't wait long the sky went
dark outside as though a black curtain
had suddenly been pulled across the
atmosphere I looked through the windows
frightened and exhilarated I was
changing I could feel it I climbed out
of the car the darkness wasn't like
night at all I don't know if I can
really describe it there were no stars
and the black was tempered with a sort
of eerie red glow that emanated from
nowhere and everywhere I spun around
I felt odd but when I looked down at
myself my body hadn't changed it was
still half decayed and misaligned like a
badly sewn doll I was confused surely it
wouldn't stay like that forever I
gripped the car door with my flaking
hands I could feel wisps all around me
like smoke or silk or tiny threads
caressing my skin I jumped and tried to
brush them away all around me in the
black were black or shapes black on
black moving across the ground flying
through the air I was terrified now then
I looked down at Celine as I watched a
dark shape fingered its way out of her
as though her shadow had taken leave of
her material body the Saleen thing
seemed to stare at me with its faceless
face James it said a high shriek escaped
my throat what are you what's going on I
told you that she didn't want the blood
James the shadow said why where am I a
gurgling chuckle issued from somewhere
amid the black wisps in the underworld
your new home my muscles tightened but I
thought I was supposed to be immortal
oh you will be the Saleen thing said it
hovered above her body like a bad dream
the great god Osiris was the lord of the
underworld but now he can move on you've
taken his place no I said this wasn't
happening it couldn't be
you tricked me Saleem the shadow laughed
again I tried to warn you but she didn't
listen the shape floated upwards
severing itself from its earthly body
enjoy your eternity James then it was
gone becoming one with the babbling
horde of dead souls I fell to the ground
the earth I knew was slipping away the
car behind me faded Celine's broken body
flickered out like a candle flame even
the grass beneath my feet degenerated
into an uncertain fog forever
I thought forever trapped in this rotted
body surrounded by the black tendrils of
the dead I raised my head but surely
there was some hope surely there was
more of Osiris's blood somewhere that
someone could drink and replace me as I
had replaced a legend surely somewhere I
stood resolute I would just have to wait
that was all I could wait with renewed
purpose I went forth to survey my
kingdom hemmed in on all sides by the
Laughing damnable shades
you